hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Gary darks
okay that's locked anyway so there was
nothing I could do about that
some weird guy making the moaning sounds
closed the door not a fool
chairs any binder seems like there might
be not there not there up there oh this
looks like a room full of secrets hey
hammer didn't I have a hammer
was it the hammer that fell well how'd
it get why are my stuff scattered all
over the place that's what I was asking
whoop-whoop Oh
game breaking OH soli oh wait no not
gamer out game breaking it all potted
plant breaking that shut up I'll hammer
your door off its hinges uh run alright
I'm watching yo bah
ah ah
ah yeah
okay little paranoid about those
paintings then again I always have okay
what's all this thing well that's all
this then premiere you've any bond the
boxes no oh no oh this was this where it
all collapsed my event and how did I get
over there I'm very confused
ah Oh hammer and my giganto it must hurt
okay just by thought isn't that isn't
that the same great that was I was just
seeing above I need light both of those
but whatever I'll make it rain with
tinderbox
oh hello these are already lit oh oh
whoa okay
you could start by putting on some
clothes old friend good God may because
I'm smarter quicker and way more
handsome than you that's right I have
one key
hey John you're probably wondering
whether wine jokey is who thing is ah
since the latest incident with our
guests we had to tighten up security
down here I won't write down the details
here but I can tell you the keys being
kept deep in storage in Section C hope
you find it without any trouble
have a good one I should look for that
wine cellar key just in case it should
be yeah that's what the note just said
gary has some [ __ ] up friends and we
are still rolling along
nothing bad gonna happen this looks like
a cave-in wouldn't be a cave-in cuz
we're not in a cave looks like a bottom
we're cave means concaving okay
nevermind the key should fit this door
and lo and behold it does huzzah the
wine saw is dark the wine cellar key
should be kept in Section C I need to
find I didn't need to before why did I
suddenly need to oh it's dark okay
okay
okay okay okay
hello mousey this is no place to be for
a mouse that's still dark but that's
game
I don't see anything here there's a lot
of rooms that I just come in and there's
nothing to get there's no purpose pledge
I got a hammer and flies hammer and
flies okay guys get out of here flies
got my finger out of my face
Oh flies I swear
storage section B whoa oh wait broom mop
broom
chairs nothing really well maybe it only
expected me to not be stupid and go in
the other sections and it just wanted me
to go straight section see that again
whenever I ever been smart oh ah ah no
no no no no I refuse no none of that
[ __ ] when I sign up for these things I
explicitly state in the contract
no mannequins I can deal with whale
calls but no mannequins I put in my
contract
Oh store Section D that's other one I
want for section C
yeah to come okay
wandering around no purpose someone
knocked over a shelf crash yep I'm not
seeing anything of use they're actually
giving me places to use my tinderboxes
so I'm grateful for that
ah and what's this then the third level
seems to be missing oh joy the machinery
hasn't finally been fixed but the new
lever that operates the door safety is
still missing
I thought you guys put it in Section
eight well we couldn't find it
sorry you will have to install the lever
for yourself it's non section I bet it's
in Section B that's why the rooms are
all emptying crap I bet it's in Section
B it probably wouldn't be in the same
section so whatever it's easy it would
be easy to miss those don't forget to
lever always with the missing levers and
you know the way levers work if it
breaks off like that it wouldn't just
fit right back in just saying
but then again video game logic okay
Rose B B was back here where the
mannequins decided to pop up fun times
fun times this is it okay
okay-y ah there it is I see yes ah very
good I found it in record time
I am splendiferous I was hoping for
something that I was just going my
inventory but I guess I can carry it
that's fine with me
still don't know why that thingy ah the
roaches
get out of here roaches don't like you
what did I tell you that people told me
about you behind my back and your back
bump your junk yeah
don't know what these do
ah come on don't tell me that I pull the
lever and made that monster spawn oh boy
whoo doggie what do I do get a barrel
back home
ah god damn it ah fudge knuckles go get
the barrel play with that oh what's up
hey oh god what's that oh yeah I'm over
there
yeah I'm still there yeah totes man oh
yeah oh you're killing me good oh yeah
you're murdering doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo just minding my own
business 30 Pierre du du du du du du du
hey okay I think I got it click and
flick your BIC ah Sisson the QI requires
must be in this session but there must
be a way to get this box out of the way
marvelous simply marvelous
fantastic Ashley excuse me pardon me I
should close the door why
oh that monster still there probably
hazy rooms are big I don't even know
what I'm looking for key looking for ya
hey turn the box
I haven't actually found the tinderbox
in a while it's been using them I mean
they're probably everywhere I just
haven't been looking very hard chairs
like all the chairs ah is a key all
right now I need to head back up what's
this n so I'll just section a you mean
there was section a right behind section
uh-huh what a waste of life
oh I see I get it that's why they gave
in well isn't that just blended makes my
life harder
ah said that Tibbs boy lots of stuff
ending mine here ah say wha no okay I'm
okay with that
I know
miss dick wait a minute it's like
something up there well interesting I
whatever those like an easter egg if you
had found a way with these boxes I bet
you could have easily stacked yourself
up on the box and then hit the lever ah
I wish I had seen that earlier I would
have tried it even if there was no
reward I would have tried it buddy the
way I have a key to the wine cellar now
I must go is my reward getting drunk on
wine preferably not the wine that makes
you blow up I know that's Alexander's
special brand
I think it's called Boone's Farm yeah
stuff will kill you okay
okay and good so far Bing
all right okay
actually the wine sell is going to have
to wait for next time I'm all out of
time for now but thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next part bye-bye